ah
oh this way
what you're never gonna make that jump
yeah watch me
oh god damn it
come on over
we'll throw us the rope it's too far
cody where there is love no distance is
too far
shut up and just throw us the rope okay
okay may relax come on huh you want the
rope you want the rope come on you want
it you wanna come on come on
all right let's swing across
yeah
whoa that that tree is huge don't worry
about it the ropes will take us to rose
in an instant
[Music]
oops
i told her i did that when i was a kid
so you're the guilty one
she's outgrown them anyway
still got it
huh
um did you build a tree house for rose
no
why do you ask there are windows oh
who could have built those
hey there's our swing finally a used hot
thing
let's get across
ugh
here we go
i i don't see a way to get the roses
room yet let's get higher
[Music]
uh you're a clay man with a rope
beware
the clay man
[Music]
wow
oh
so
okay is that our pot lid what's it doing
up here looks like a pulley controls it
hey look cody a door a door in a tree i
don't like it we got to get to rose's
room can't you see how far away it is
yes i can see how far away it is that's
why we got to keep moving yeah maybe
there's someone inside you can help us
really
wait what what are you doing we don't
know what's inside there come on it
might be a shortcut to the house yeah
but what if it's not what if it's
who sent you
no one uh we come in peace we're trying
to get to the house
house what's your business there
we haven't got time for this is this a
shortcut or not
great
told you this was a bad idea not helpful
come on help me push
[Music]
it's too heavy ride the glass jar but at
least we can see through it oh that's
great mate we're imprisoned but the view
is amazing
dad
dad i have to tell you something it's
important have you heard of this book by
um dr hakeem
he says that it's important to forgive
each other
because then you can become friends
again
if you want you can borrow the book
okay
you're busy
sorry
cody are you okay yeah
been better but i'm okay
are you working for the wasps
what
the wasps don't play dumb did they send
you here to kill us what
kill you no we're not working for any
wasps we'll see you side you're on
pull a switch you got it chief
boss it doesn't look like they're on the
wasps team and why don't they die maybe
they have superpowers what if they can
help us
let's find out
abort
oh are you okay yeah you yeah oh just
about that was terrible horrendous
hey hi
okay hey there mr uh mr big squirrel
so you want to get to the house
yes
we can get you there
really you that's very um
kind
all one condition
what do you mean
follow me
come on it's a terrible idea come on
cody i don't want to go
wow
they must be real hoarders
hey hey that's our remote control
they stole it those sneaky rodents
look our family photos what could they
want with those i don't know oh you look
good
hey that's my underwear
you used to love that underwear used to
[Music]
the wasps have invaded our tree wiped
out most of our tribe
you two must kill them
what
we can't kill those crazy creatures you
nuts
no offense don't worry you'll just
survive two of them against a whole
swarm of them surely will die that's why
you're going to need these my latest in
cyber haze nut technology the tree sap
shaky 57.
[Music]
combined with a drill buzzer x200
[Music]
boom
there's one more thing
we sent in an undercover agent who could
operate our queen robot
as planned the wasps believed the robot
was their real queen but instead of
wiping out the wasps our agent was
seduced by its power and switched sides
so
kill the wasps and the agent in the
robot and we'll help you get to the
house
understood
ah yeah sure but
isn't there a more civilized way that we
can
i really don't want to have to kill
giant wasps well you wouldn't have to if
you'd cleaned out the hive
what what what hive
remember
in the real world in our tree
i asked you so many times and you
promised to get rid of it yeah yeah fine
fine but we wouldn't even be here if you
hadn't knocked on the squirrel's door
well at least they're gonna lead us to
the house what are you kidding me you
you believe that i don't trust those
squirrels they stole my underwear oh
believe me that was a blessing oh
really
well at least my underwear is now a
sophisticated part of a flying machine
my sincerely doubter can fly of course
you do
you know what
i can't wait to get back to my real body
so that we can get the forced oh me too
hey
hey what now i guess it's time to kill
some wasps what alone don't worry we've
got weapons you mean these homemade
squirrel diy drill basser tap shaky
things you saw how powerful they are
that's drill baz
[Music]
what's that hanging there
down we go
what you're listening to is another one
of my latest
you'll find them at the keeper
hey
try igniting the sap
[Music]
[Music]
gosh those squirrels weren't kidding
yeah
this is a war zone
look cody
shooting targets let's practice
wow this is impressive i'm getting
spooky by this place can we please turn
back i'm afraid that won't be possible
we've sealed the doors behind you to
protect against the wasps your only way
out is
on the other side
[Music]
yes
uh
uh
[Music]
hey
huh
[Music]
this one's ready
it's zapped up
uh
nice progress
down we go
so
hey
hmm
[Music]
looks like squirrel attack isn't
foolproof
oh
[Music]
ugh
ah
hey
[Music]
ah
and he was ready
uh-huh well this got interesting they're
experimenting on a skateboard
they really are nuts look at those tesla
coils
these squirrels seem far more capable
than i thought
those barbaric wasps could never
understand the potential of technology
[Music]
uh
oh
[Music]
these red buttons look interesting
[Music]
yep
[Music]
i felt that one nae
[Music]
uh
sorry
[Music]
that wasn't very funny
you look fine though
i see you found our nut bath and sauna
machine painting of course we haven't
worked out all the
kinks
hey
this lid looks loose
i don't like the look of this
looks like something was kept in here
yeah
something big
whatever it was it's gone now
it sapped up
something's coming
give me a match here
[Music]
i think that's the last
oh
[Music]
oh
huh
fire it up man
[Music]
hey may
i think there's a bridge here let's
knock it down then
ugh
oh
hey
guitar football
and you thought i threw it out
yeah sorry about that
rose and i used to play with it all the
time
just another thing the squirrels have
taken from us
hey mate come here
ready to fall into the hole
bye bye
easy
down the train cody
oh you're going down
[Music]
[Music]
one win and you're already a master
oh man
my legs worked
my feet hurt when we get out of this
mess
i'm having a cold beef
i'm having two what if we're stuck here
oh stuck like this you don't know that
we'll get to rose and break the spell
what if we never get to her please stop
talking and keep running
who's driving those minecarts
[Music]
[Music]
where did these tracks even go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Music]
okay
but beyonce
once inside you will be on your own
may the eighth hole be with you
get down
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
here
[Music]
my shoes
oh
oh
[Applause]
did we get it yeah
looks like it
let's get through that vault
we are searching for them supreme what
queen search harder bring them to me
yes supreme was queen
that is one scary queen
don't worry it's just a squirrel inside
a robot yeah
a very big robot
it's trying to kill us you know maybe we
should just turn back
are you cheeking it out no no no we were
just you know exploring the uh premises
right i think you look scared like doing
little tickets no not at all we were
just scouting preparing for the mission
yeah right preparation is key good but
remember collaboration is also key this
is a very dangerous operation
thanks for reminding us you're welcome
man hey
[Music]
[Laughter]
that book is really annoying
oh what now they're watched
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
hey
huh
oh
oh these guys can't hurt us
but those can
down
[Music]
[Music]
there you are
no no no no we don't want to fight
are you the best
already
[Music]
weapons of their own oh
yeah but we're kicking some butt here at
least hey you're pretty good with that
match gun
thanks cody
you too
keep up the sap
oh
oh huh
hey isn't this your camera may
huh so were the squirrels running away
from something
all right there he goes
quick into positions
the perfect backdrop for my war hero
photo
nice shot
oh have to pose quick
not bad
cool
whoa
i think they're bringing out the big
guns now
they call me the exterminator they
really don't
how do you like that
leave us alone
[Music]
wow
hey don't do that
oh
oh
wow
oh
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh shoot
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
now what
i think we need to head that way
come on may we can't swim in this
[Music]
we're going by boat
huh help me out what
my boat this is a boat all right come on
[Music]
don't we need like oars or something we
don't need oars cody we've got an engine
we do where uh it's in your hand what
not just a wooden face mate yeah very
funny
all right
[Music]
all guns should be as handy as this
everything has multiple features we just
need to see them so you're an engineer
you know about gadgets nature
that's not really helping us
[Music]
[Music]
cody
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
come on i've never driven a boat
[Music]
yeah
but what are they doing
all hands
it's roaring ahead
[Music]
oh
[Music]
ah
wow
they are beautiful
yeah
deadly beauty jellyfish can be lethal we
better get moving
look the light let's go
cody steer straight ahead aye aye
captain
hmm
[Music]
ah
let there be light
whoa
beautiful
whoa
cool this must be the squirrel's history
is that supposed to be us
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
huh
cody is the plan to swim right through
that wall
hang
[Music]
on this isn't my fault
oh
you know i am getting really tired of
falling well be grateful you're in good
shape oh yeah thanks me
i meant good shape in this world
oh
i see so you're saying i'm in bad shape
in my real body
oh i didn't say that
hey i am made of clay could you run jump
and fall like this in your real body
no exactly so enjoy it while it lasts
yeah
okay
hey cody that looks like a shooting
range
oh
hey mate come here
[Music]
get ready to lose i'm aiming to win so
am i
watch and learn
okay
all righty
i know how to handle the plunger
[Music]
he's away
[Music]
i got this
easy
[Music]
yes
boring
come
on that's it
hey man i'm a sharp shooter shooting
plungers doesn't require precision
that looks like an elevator over there
we have to cross over yeah
but
that's a deep hit
uh
where are we going only one way out
they're back with their crazy sauce
now
oh
[Music]
[Music]
it
yeah
oh
whoa
what is this place
uh
i don't know but
they look pretty angry yeah they do
oh you ready for this i'm not sure
yeah stupid question
damn
[Music]
[Music]
ah
uh
[Music]
ah
[Music]
wow
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
ah
oh
oh
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
damn what's up
what about this
[Music]
ah
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
uh
so
ah
[Music]
wow
[Music]
oh
[Music]
wait wait wait wait don't kill me
i'm just a beetle
i don't even like the wasps so why are
you on their side i'm a mercenary i
fight for anyone who pays me the food
shelf what food huh worms
slugs larvae no i'm a vegetarian and
gluten-free i get paid nectar
okay
well uh you know the queen she has all
the nectar
so if you help us take her down you can
have as much nectar as you want
i can yes he can have it all
what are we waiting for come on jump one
[Music]
yummy
[Music]
no definitely not
hey you better not get us killed if you
want that nectar
no still no shoot them
nice one mae
oh
we're running out of trees
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
intruders how dare you challenge the
queen
a challenger
listen we know you're not the real queen
yeah you're a robot
i'm the supreme
exactly
[Music]
we're slowly tipping away
wow
technology
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
ah
is
[Music]
technology
[Music]
shield swords
[Music]
oh
wow
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
slash
ugh
oh
[Music]
oh
oh
oh
[Music]
i am
[Music]
oh she's actually really furry and sweet
yeah
no no no i am the wasp queen
no no no i told you see it's a robot
it's a stupid
[Music]
yes
[Music]
wait
[Music]
shoot the next attack
[Music]
oh
are you okay
i have nothing to live for now i'm no
longer a wasp queen
what's the point if you can't be special
but you are special you are one of the
noblest pollinators in nature
i i am yeah of course bees pollinate
crops that feed 90
of the human population without you guys
humans would just die he's right
really so i am special
no you're a traitor
a youtube why haven't you killed the
traitor she helped save us yeah i'm
special yeah and all the wasps have gone
i mean we don't need to kill her do we
huh oh so you're on the same team now
shoot them all
[Music]
good luck hey
take us with you hey we just saved your
furry ass
come on cody over here
you drive what
hey this is a plane it's not a station
wagon just fly where's the gas
[Music]
man the cannons i want air coverage code
nuts hunt them down go go go
[Music]
hey hahaha
[Music]
just help me out and clear the way
wow
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
keep oh steady cody keep it stop trying
let's go straight all right
[Music]
all right well
don't trust the plane
you're distracted just make them down
[Music]
[Music]
ah
we got more trouble ahead
behind us
[Music]
oh this is escalating quickly
[Music]
hey
[Music]
time to say goodbye to the doll can't
wait to smash your wooden face
[Music]
wow
[Music]
hey watch it move
my squirrel battalion will avenge me
[Music]
i'm here
oh that was close you're welcome yeah uh
thanks meg
hey
that fight that was epic
thanks ready yeah well
you know
not the roses yep
[Music]
you think the squirrels will be mad
about the clay
well they shouldn't have stolen from us
in the first place
i'll never look at a squirrel the same
way again
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
hey
there's the shed around our house
here we go
[Music]
hey
[Music]
oh
[Music]
mummy
look who i found mimba boon
remember him
oh
do you have that headache again
okay
i won't bother you
but but when you feel better maybe we
can play with moon baboon again
and all the other space tweets you got
for me
we haven't played with them in a long
time
oh and i talked to dad
i think he wants you to become friends
again
[Music]
just wanted you to know
[Music]
oh
that is the last time i'm flying by the
seat of your pants oh ha-ha you're a
real comedian you know that oh thank you
look there she is oh i miss her do you
think she's okay
she looks fine i mean she's playing like
nothing happened thank goodness
let's go and talk to her yeah but we
should be careful we don't want to scare
her are you saying i'm too harsh with
her no
no i meant she might get scared when she
sees us i mean look at us we've turned
into a couple of dolls remember of
course i remember
are you really ready to talk to rob why
not she's our daughter well can you talk
to her without fighting each other of
course we can rose isn't the problem
here
you'll see
i don't think you are ready wait is he
trying to stop us i think that he is and
are we gonna let him
no
yep
[Music]
you